because we are live right now here on
lamb and Cheyenne with fire deputy chief
sand Mills who is here to tell us more
about how this fire started thank you so
much for joining us can you tell us you
know what exactly you guys know oh I I
did speak with the honor and he stated
that uh one of his employees witnessed a
spark in one of the cardboard pallets on
the back
um and then from there they try to use
an extinguisher to put it out but
obviously to no avail that they weren't
able to do that so then they called us
and all
to put out this fire too I mean with the
winds as is helping or hurting you guys
um it depends on what side of the win
you want to be on um if you're if you're
upwind it is what it is if you're down
when it's a little bit worse so um the
structure that the owner was concerned
about is the winds working in his favor
but obviously if the buildings that are
to the north of the incident they're
going to be affected either by uh
um usually that smoke and how long do
you guys think you'll be out here looks
like the fire is calming down as you
guys work towards something uh well you
know you always hate to speculate how
long we're going to be doing something
but it does look like it's calming down
now which is great however we start
going to do a little bit of overhaul
we're going to find some hot spots and
some different Pockets there that we're
gonna have to keep overhauling so we
might be a little bit longer than that I
imagine several more hours perfect well
thank you so much we appreciate it and
of course we'll be out here with more
information to give you guys as this
develops reporting live Mary Jane lieza
8 News Now